monsieur le ministre vous avez il y a
peu expliqué que vous souhaitiez parler
aux fournisseurs d'énergie ben écoutez
vous en avez un qui est tout trouvé sous
la main et que vous contrôlez
entièrement il s'appelle EDF donc
mettez-vous au travail et rapidement
pour apporter des solutions je rappelle
je rappelle que pour EDF nous payons ici
les choix funeste menés depuis 10 ans
pour arrêter la production d'électricité
nucléaire on en paye très charmant le
prix
monsieur le ministre
je l'ai dit nous avons besoin d'avoir
une vision stratégique en domaine
énergétique pour travailler sur les
énergies renouvelables pour travailler
sur l'autonomie énergétique et pour
travailler sur notre souveraineté
énergétique notamment dans le
renouvelable et dans le nucléaire tout
ça doit en plus améliorer le solde de
notre balance commerciale et enfin
Monsieur le Ministre TPE PME ETI grandes
entreprises les entreprises de France
ont besoin d'un soutien adapté mais
encore faut-il travailler en constance
avec ses représentants d'entreprises il
compte sur vous la France a besoin d'un
État fort à ses côtés